when we sat down we also talked about
the chin we talked about the chin
multiple times yeah and you know did you
see the did you see when michael was
here on the podcast or no you didn't see
it
yeah yeah would you so you saw one the
video about chin or no did you see it i
think i did okay so you heard what rudy
said about chennai he was never a number
he thought he was number two but he was
really number six how long is that clip
by the way is it a shorter collection is
this the one where michael took a walk
with uh
with uh no no this is uh no not this one
i want you to oh yeah that's it yeah so
go from the part what he says about do
you have the beginning part what they
say about the chin yeah did we play that
last time or no
uh no we started okay so why don't you
go and play what michael and sammy said
about the chin and then go to what rudy
says about the chin
said
what he wanted to say he had the walls
he was going to usher he had the brains
to save this is people that goes in
ocean he told another boss john was the
boss told another boss
that we were going to do a big raid
and we were going to arrest the number
one or number two people in each family
they did that about two weeks before
well chen giganti
who thought he was number two in the
japanese family but he wasn't
because everybody hated him
they told him he was number two it was
like number eight
chin is the guy who walked around in the
robes and acted like he was crazy well
he was crazy
he was a
borderline personality disorder in the
military he was actually i think
officially
officially uh diagnosed as apparently
schizophrenic he was yeah so if anybody
played that he played it up
so
this information comes out
one of the issues comes in until the
unit you couldn't believe this
chin checked himself into austin
he thinks we're going to arrest him
can be very disappointed when we don't
arrest him
did you end up with the award eventually
but not for that i got it we're not for
that so it it it just played to the
whole world they've been they've been
lying to him for several years tell you
send your number two you're number two
now yeah i wanted to yes again since
crazy don't listen
wow fat tony knew he was nuts so he made
him think he was number two but he never
he said how come i don't go to her oh
come on i come i don't go to the
to the to the commission meetings i'm
number two they say you know chin you're
too high profile
with that bad throat but all that stuff
if they see you walking in they'll know
where we're having the meetings
he is so [ __ ] off base with that
whole conversation it's incredible
first of all i knew and i had a dozen
serious meetings with chin
he was extremely smart
extremely smart
he was number two
under fat tony for one reason the boss
before fat tony who died
i can't think of his [ __ ] name but it
doesn't matter he he brought in chen
chen was
that the gangster part of that he
brought in chip and he says i'm gonna
make flat tone
the boss
it's my decision
i want you to promise me you don't kill
him
be his number two
and
time you'll become number one
promise me
jen promised him he allowed that to
happen
jim was five times more vicious
smarter
in every way had a bigger following
than fat tone
tony i loved him he's a great guy
um
so that's the way it felt so it's wrong
and then at i went to commission
meetings
i was there just for security when chin
fat tony came
and uh
paul was there there's even a tape of
that meeting
when guys are coming out of the house
not inside or anything like that
but anyway
then he told fred tony it's time for you
to step down
and he stepped down and chin was number
one
and i was at those commission meetings
with john
even after paul
which it
and benny eggs was his underboss so he
don't know what the [ __ ] he's talking
about at all
and he wasn't stupid
he did this little scam
and he put himself in and out of
hospitals so that when they call
when he when he's indicted
and they call doctors and things and
that he he's beated for years he doesn't
understand
so you can't charge a man who doesn't
understand what the charges are what it
is he's mentally insane he played that
in my opinion that's the only thing i
didn't like about chin
he played that too much
one time
agents came to his house he ran upstairs
he got a naked under the shower with an
umbrella with his mother
you do that in front of your mother it's
a little excessive
for me
and if you're not bothered by going to
prison
then take your billions or might into
whatever he had and leave the mafia [ __ ]
them off you walk away
which
somewhere along the line you have to
have a little bit more integrity
when
my lawyer
went on a visit where he was in texas
after he was convicted
my lawyer was representing somebody
and
he in the room
and chin
had already been convicted he came out
he was talking
perfect on his visits and everything
else because they found him guilty that
they matter no more
he was talking perfect so my lawyer says
sami he's not crazy oh he was talking
perfect
i heard him the whole time
i said i know it was an act so i don't
even know what he's saying
so he's absolutely wrong and i and i can
give you story after story
which i'm not going to give you
right now
of meetings i have with him that are
important some of them are on my podcast
um he was a sharpie's attack
and i don't know anybody anybody in the
mafia who would have said [ __ ] [ __ ]
him he will kill you in a second
flat
no hesitation with him
none
everybody under him loved him
just
chin yes bobby manner
benny eggs
all of them
loved him
and he had ran a tight ship and a tight
family
so
he's totally wrong
and
so all you people who love him
when he talks like that doesn't know
what he's talking about
i would like for me and him to go to a
doctor together
so i can get my foot out of his ass
because it would take a few doctors
rudy my foot would fit perfect
in his ass tony and eight and a half can
you show us what that would look like
with gerard right now just so we get a
an actual glimpse no no
something like that would actually go
down
the show
[Music]
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]